what's going on what's going on this
can't be good
maybe our headache what what are you
doing here
the [ __ ]
this is a guy who performed surgery room
before oh can you take yeah you can see
me I try to cut it off earlier
okay
we got that Oh we're gonna use that good
now we can pick up the key now we can
fish yeah move you're gonna pick up that
tinderbox I'm trying to stuff in a way
come on there you go that's a nice bed
it looks very comfortable all right so
let's combine these two
No maybe I don't have to maybe we can
put the bucket on this yeah exactly
the roof needs to be wheeled in before
the buckets the answer is to leave it on
the side
did you see it oh there is that's down
up nice okay
oh now now it said flip so that's
I'm so scared that he's gonna be like
behind me when I you're gonna fish him
up he's like hello okay we got a bucket
filled with water but I don't want a big
bucket filled with water I want a key
they have to try again
No
what am I supposed to do with a bucket
full of water see I got to try again
no I can't spill it
what am I supposed to do with a bucket
full of [ __ ] water
god dammit find a key to open the door
leading out of the area
I said pipe that's a well we're in the
in the diary
looks like piping oh you did yeah I
don't remember that your soul pipe there
okay we're better like I don't think you
can use though right
we're between two cells there yeah no I
seen this everywhere there's nothing to
chip
it's got a chance to sell
yeah that's true it's got to be close to
his cell
huh oh [ __ ] I bit my tongue ouch
ah so many puzzles I'm getting tired of
it good maybe it's something to do with
him ice wake him up then what would be
lovely
there's got to be something about him
why else would he like appear again
no my speaker
maybe this thing is like scared of water
or something yeah nope it only worked
with acid and even if it didn't work you
wouldn't help us what am I supposed to
do with a bucket of water mmm
put it down the pipe so that key floats
up yeah that's true
that's smart let's keep thieves
she doesn't float not there the pipe
which pipe
account
oh [ __ ] it worked
dude you're smart
we got it well you guys I don't know
what I'll but thank you
oh yes Oh God
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh I have no idea but I don't
want to find out I can hear footsteps
behind me Oh Oh fine
oh [ __ ] come back oh you can't hear the
sound but I can that sound makes it so
[ __ ] hard like a dragon coming oh
yeah it sounded so I don't want to play
this game anymore usually I take a break
after something like that oh we're up
here hey I know where we are this is
where we on another note what what's
going on oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
loading screen
18th of August 8th
oh this is shortly after the beginning
no it's not I'm stupid that'd be nice
losing on me and I fear for my life more
than ever oh [ __ ]
white
are you controller yeah we're reliving
our memory
have you noticed some people no never
because in every way
have you noticed like in every game
there's a change of gameplay in the
ending so like this like something that
never happened before so I can tell that
we're pretty close to finishing this but
I think I can understand like why he
wanted to raise his memory because he
did some nasty stuff
yeah oh [ __ ] these leaves have been
following me with the entire game I
don't know what's up with those I hope
there's a reason to it
Tilly cherry blossom now it's it's rose
leaves
now we can use the bucket the water
maybe didn't use it okay oh yeah I did
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I was like why the hell would you pick
it up by the way I know I okay whatever
and it's gonna stop talking Oh
[ __ ] I don't want to go in here ya go
Coco
oh oh look at this place yeah
yeah
there's no if the father penis unless it
see the monster cuz kill was run before
I guess yeah seriously do you mean to
see my oh [ __ ] I don't know I guess I
can see him you know I when you died I
was like what happened you didn't see it
no it went pretty quick though I guess
you can watch later yeah
don't like this place okay so we're
gonna go say hello to our grip again I
guess a grip ended up with that behind
me
down on this I can't run anymore it's a
Millie oh it's because I'm in the stairs
it's redeuce everywhere yeah keeps
happening every place I will visit this
stuff [ __ ] haunts me so what does oh
[ __ ] it scares the hell out of me that's
why this [ __ ] does goddamnit
what's going on in here oh this wasn't
open before or was it yeah I've been in
here I think I can you think this has
something to do with the war BAM I think
it is actually
so you should use that yes
nothing are the heat
what let's pick up Gotham share what the
hell
I guess I guess I can block him if he
comes
where does that mean any comp or pasta
share well it's the worth it worth a
shot
I can do anything with that I can just
what
the hell is going on there
oh I know it's gonna be there the poison
ivy or whatever it was don't you think
and he is like screwy yeah it worked
should not squeeze the juice out of the
gland without a container we have a
continue luckily
you can't do this right now why not what
do I have to wait for oh well I guess I
need the container for something else
first that either what about here
No
this is confusing
why can't undo this right now there's
something I got to do with this you know
you leave that up yeah there's something
I need to do with this glass of jar wait
No
this is really confusing
I'm gonna set up the sphere here with
all the stuff I've collected but
apparently I can't start it
any ideas mmm
look around slowly
all right
you shouldn't have to like jump this
stuff actually
but I can't pick that up yet
I think you should squeeze that one try
to adjust but it said I couldn't do it
it said yeah